the movie opens up in an elementary
school where a teacher asks her students
about their dad's profession one of them
says that her father is a doctor while
another says he's a truck driver however
when it's little Max's turn he reveals
that his father is a liar following this
the movie cuts to a few hours later
where we see Max waiting for his dad
Fletcher to arrive he was supposed to
come at 4pm but it's already 6 and
there's no sign of him even Max's mom
Audrey has grown tired of his behavior
however just as the mother-son Duo is
about to give up Fletcher arrives in his
fancy car and starts making excuses he
says that he was stuck in an important
meeting with his boss the innocent Max
believes it right away and hugs his dad
tightly with this show of affection it
appears that the three are a normal
family but suddenly a guy shows up out
of nowhere and kisses Audrey it is then
revealed that Fletcher and Audrey got
divorced some months back and the latter
is currently dating the guy named Jerry
Fletcher only visits the family so he
can spend time with his son in the next
scene we get to know a bit more about
this Fletcher guy being a seasoned
lawyer he is accustomed to lying in
court all the time however Fletcher's
lied so much that the disease has
shifted to his personal life as well
even if it is a simple question Fletcher
will lie and make it more dramatic
currently he has brought his son on the
pretext of taking him to a wrestling
match but Fletcher takes Max to his
workplace instead saying he has some
unfinished work the biggest wrestling
related upset since Logan Paul joined
The Fray the poor boy who clearly knows
that he isn't going to watch any
wrestling today doesn't say a word the
most precious thing for him is to spend
time with his dad later as Fletcher
makes his way towards his office he
gives fake compliments to all the
colleagues he meets for instance when a
woman with a ridiculous hairstyle
approaches him he tells her that she
looks fantastic Fletcher even tells an
extremely obese man that he's looking
slim today after a while his assistant
Greta secretly tells him that it's his
son's birthday tomorrow being the
absent-minded dad that he has Fletcher
completely forgot about it this
panicking however Greta brings forward a
package and calms him down saying she
has already taken care of Max's present
finally we are introduced to Fletcher's
boss Miranda she is a cunning woman who
only wants one thing in life to have
coitus Miranda often forces Fletcher to
come to her house and do it with her
promising that she'll promote him
however she always eats up her words as
soon as they finish that night when the
clock hits 12 Fletcher hands his son to
present and it turns out to be baseball
gloves but despite the attractive gift
Max is unhappy as his dad doesn't have
time to play with him in response
Fletcher promises to come to his
birthday party the next morning a new
client named Samantha arrives at
Fletcher's Law Firm she is revealed to
be a gold digger who is looking to
divorce her husband and get 50 percent
of his wealth the only problem is that
Samantha has had an open affair with
another guy this means that she is the
reason behind the divorce and winning
the case would be nearly impossible
however Fletcher with his cunning lies
as usual assures cement that she can win
the case he even suggests that she fight
for her children's custody because if
she wins she'll get an even bigger
settlement than 50 percent as expected
Samantha likes the idea and agrees right
away after the meeting ends and
impressed Miranda approaches Fletcher
and forcefully kisses him she then
invites him to her house that night
saying she will have the promotion
papers ready the movie then cuts to
Max's birthday party where a clown is
seen entertaining the audience everyone
seems to be enjoying themselves except
for Max he is upset that his father has
not shown up when Audrey learns of this
she immediately calls Fletcher and
explains that their son is missing him a
lot however the crazy lawyer is in the
middle of a romantic session with his
boss as usual he lies that he can't make
it because he is busy with work Coulda
just told the truth he's actually busy
with Henriette Weinstein later as it is
time to blow out the birthday candles
Max makes an unexpected wish he is tired
of his dad's lies so he wants God to
make sure Fletcher cannot lie again
although the innocent boy says it out of
superstitious hope God actually listens
to him and fulfills his wish in the
morning when Fletcher wakes up with
Miranda he surprisingly cannot stop
himself from insulting her when the boss
inquires how he felt last night Fletcher
honestly says that she doesn't have the
stamina like she used to this angers
Miranda and she kicks him out of the
house later as Fletcher leaves his
apartment he meets a beautiful lady on
the elevator the two initiate a
conversation and the girl says that she
is very popular in the building
impressed Fletcher tries to complement
her looks but ends up saying that she's
popular because of her chest he also
expresses his desire to grab them right
now mama
I love that scene as expected this anger
is the lady and she slaps him tightly
following this Fletcher heads to the
courtroom to defend Samantha a lot of
serious people are in attendance
implying that the case is a high profile
one soon Samantha's husband Richard and
his lawyer approached Fletcher and warn
him that he will lose the case the
lawyer explains that they have
incriminating evidence of Samantha
having an extramarital affair so the
case is totally in their favor Fletcher
tries to argue by making up a lie but
fails miserably no matter how hard he
tries he just can't speak what he wants
to after a while the judge enters the
court and the atmosphere becomes tense
Fletcher realizing that he is in no
condition to take on the case requests
to postpone the prosecution but the
judge declines so during the break he
rushes back to his office to recuperate
at this point Fletcher is confused about
what's happening to him every time he
tries to fabricate a lie he ends up
saying his inner thoughts on a normal
day he would falsely compliment all his
colleagues but today he blatantly makes
fun of their appearances Fletcher tells
the crazy-haired woman from earlier that
she should become bald while the obese
guy is told that he will soon die of a
heart attack panicked Fletcher locks
himself in his room and grabs a blue pen
he tries to say that it is a red pen but
the words just won't come out he ends up
saying the pen is blue after a while
Fletcher realizes that he had promised
to pick up Max from school so he quickly
calls Audrey and tells her that he is
busy with work in response the latter
mentions that she already knew he
wouldn't come she then inquires what he
was doing last night and despite
Fletcher trying his best to make up a
lie he ends up revealing that he was
banging his boss he then breaks the
telephone and starts screaming on the
other hand Max sadly asks his mom if he
is not a good boy no matter how hard he
tries to be with his dad Fletcher just
won't pay him any attention he also
reveals that last night he wished his
dad would only say the truth from now on
however he is not sure if the wish
worked hearing all this Audrey Comforts
him saying his dad is just busy these
days and that he will surely come around
in seen Fletcher repairs his broken
telephone and calls Audrey once again he
frantically says that something is
happening to him because of which he
cannot control himself however Audrey
who is fed up with Fletcher
disappointing their son time and time
again reveals that she's moving to
Boston with her boyfriend and Matt the
Revelation worries Fletcher so he
disconnects the call and rushes to
Audrey's home but unfortunately along
the way he is pulled over for speeding
Fletcher's usual tries to make up a lie
but ends up Landing himself in hot water
he inadvertently blurts out how he has
never paid any fines despite being
warned by the authorities many times
later Fletcher is asked to pay sixteen
hundred dollars as outstanding fines
which have been accumulated over a
period of 20 years adjusted for today's
inflation that's six billion dollars but
since he doesn't have that kind of cash
on him he calls Audrey for help once she
arrives and gets him out Fletcher pleads
with her to stay saying he cannot afford
to lose his son he asserts that in this
chaotic life that he's living Max is the
only good thing he has as he continues
to plead Audrey becomes emotional and
agrees but she warns him that if he
doesn't visit Max in the evening she
will definitely catch a flight to Boston
the next morning she also reveals how
much the little boy loves him last night
he made a wish asking God to make sure
his father never lies again hearing this
Fletcher has taken aback and he finally
realizes why all this is happening to
him so without wasting any time he heads
to his son's school and takes him out in
the middle of his classes Fletcher then
buys a cake for him and asks him to
reverse yesterday's wish the innocent
boy complies without any questions but
once he's done he says that it didn't
work Max further reveals the last night
he made the wish with an honest heart as
he really wanted to stop his dad from
lying but now he can't do the same
frustrated Fletcher returns to his
office and confides in his assisted
Greta about everything that has been
happening today the latter thinks that
he is joking so she tests him by asking
a trick question unfortunately Fletcher
who cannot say a lie makes insensitive
jokes about her causing her to storm off
in Anger Fletcher's problems continue to
mount as Miranda overhears his
conversation and learns about his
condition to put him in a tough spot she
takes him to the conference room where
the higher-ups are currently having a
meeting Miranda knows that Fletcher will
make fun of them and to her Delight he
does just that Fletcher targets the CEO
and calls him out for always farting he
even calls him a big fat loser this
silences the entire room for a while but
then everyone starts laughing
surprisingly the CEO finds the joke very
funny and he thanks Fletcher for making
his day don't try that one in real life
in the next scene the court resumes the
prosecution and all the participants
take their positions the first one to go
is Richard's lawyer she brings forward a
tape and plays it and to everyone's
disgust it is the audio of Samantha
having a vigorous coitus with her lover
Fletcher tries to counter it with his
usual tactics but of course he only
makes the situation worse when nothing
works he drinks a lot of water and asks
for a washroom break there Fletcher gets
a strange idea and starts beating
himself mercilessly a while later a
guard escorts him into the courtroom in
a bruised and battered State he has made
it look like someone has assaulted him
however when the judge asks if he can
continue Fletcher truthfully says yes
even though he wanted to say the
opposite this impresses the judge he
applauds Fletcher for being a determined
lawyer and as a reward he adjourns the
prosecution for 15 minutes during the
break Fletcher calls his son and
reassures him that he will make it
tonight he also mentions how much Max
means to him and the latter reciprocates
the laugh after talking to his son
Fletcher feels reinvigorated and
energized and as he is about to re-enter
the courtroom he runs into Samantha and
her actual lover Kenneth the three
discussed for a while and decide to use
Kenneth as a witness to clarify
everything following this the
prosecution resumes and when it's
Fletcher's turn he orders Kenneth to be
his witness however since he cannot lie
he starts asking irrelevant questions to
his own witness putting him in a tough
situation when Kenneth has had enough he
bursts out in anger and reveals that he
did sleep with Samantha looks like
Richard's not the only dick in
Samantha's life this Revelation stuns
the entire courtroom and the judge
declares the case in Richard's favor but
surprisingly there is still one more
twist left in the case as Fletcher goes
to his seat and puts his head down his
eyes catch the attention of a document
the document enlists all of Samantha's
personal details including her age
weight and complexity Fletcher being a
talented lawyer immediately digs upon
the information and reveals that
Samantha has actually reduced her actual
age when she got married she was only
17. AKA a minor in the state of
California a minor cannot sign a legal
document including a prenuptial
agreement this means that Richard broke
the rules while marrying her and so he
is the culprit here the information
stuns the entire room and the judge also
reverses his decision Against All Odds
Samantha has won the case and has been
rewarded with 50 percent of Richard's
Fortune the selates Fletcher and his
team as they have won and hear
impossible case in the most dire of
circumstances however the gold digger
Samantha is still not done as told by
Fletcher earlier she demands custody of
her children because it will grant her
more wealth unfortunately for Richard
the judge agrees to this as well and
forced to give up 75 percent of his
wealth Richard cries and pleads saying
he cannot live without his children but
the decision stands firm when Fletcher
Witnesses the emotional sight he finally
understands the true meaning of
Parenthood he regrets having neglected
his son all his life despite the latter
always longing for him so he makes a
promise to never ignore Max again
Fletcher also tries to plead with the
judge to return Richard's kids to him he
claims he broke the entire system and
told a lot of lies unfortunately the
judge finds this offensive and Fletcher
is taken into custody in the police
station Fletcher calls Audrey to bail
him out but she berates him for not
fulfilling his promise yet again he
didn't visit Max even though he assured
him that he would Audrey then reveals
that they are on their way to the
airport and hangs up the call the news
devastate Fletcher and he finally
accepts his situation but as he is
waiting in his prison cell someone bails
him out it is none other than his caring
assistant Greta she even encourages him
to go after his son saying it's now or
never taking her advice Fletcher gets
into his car and speeds his way to the
airport unfortunately despite his
efforts he learns that the passengers
have already boarded the plane currently
it is about to take off in an act of
desperation the resilient Fletcher
hijacks a mobile staircase and goes
after the plane he then throws one of
his shoes at it causing the pilot to
abort the takeoff the plan is successful
and the flight is canceled but Fletcher
loses his balance and ends up crashing
later as he is being stretchered off Max
approaches him delightfully the two chat
for a while and Fletcher with tears in
his eyes promises to be by his son's
side forever seeing them so close Jerry
and Audrey also decide to cancel their
plans for Boston following this the
movie cuts to one year later and we see
Audrey and Fletcher together they are
currently celebrating their son's ninth
birthday just like the previous instance
Max closes his eyes and asks for a wish
and when he opens them he sees his
parents making out Fletcher jokingly
asks if he wished for them to be
together but Max replies that he just
wanted a pair of rollerblades the movie
ends as the three laugh it off while
poor Jerry is nowhere to be seen
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching